on April 8th 2020 a few hundred people
in Florida broke the state's
stay-at-home order to go wait in this
line hundreds of thousands of people had
lost their jobs and applied for
unemployment benefits through Florida's
online system but the people in this
line had come out to get these paper
applications because for thousands in
Florida the website wasn't working
problems from almost the moment it went
online site crashes and glitches a
process to file is nearly impossible
Americans have lost their jobs all over
the country but the kind of help they
can get depends on what state they live
in
that's because the US doesn't really
have one unemployment system it has 53
of them each state and territory has
their own and the differences between
them are huge in places like New Jersey
and Massachusetts before the economy
crashed a little more than half of all
workers without jobs were able to
collect unemployment benefits in Florida
less than 10 percent of unemployed
people who are getting them in places
like Florida the complicated hard to use
unemployment system isn't a mistake it's
doing exactly what it was designed to do
I haven't really had an answer from
anyone oh man look or they may is going
by and June 1st is gonna come and I have
no idea what I'm gonna do
back during the Great Recession lots of
people were out of work state
unemployment systems were in overdrive
in many states the funds that fed those
systems were running out of cash so lots
of states including Florida raise taxes
on businesses that made a lot of
business owners unhappy in the 2010 and
2012 elections several states elected
Republican governors who promised to
reverse those tax hikes any tax increase
kills jobs in 2011 when rick scott took
office florida employers paid three
hundred $19 per worker and unemployment
taxes by 2019 when he left they were
paying $50 per worker the lowest rate in
the country but that meant florida
system was underfunded again so the new
governor and the Republican legislature
started finding ways to pay less money
to fewer people they cut weekly payments
and reduced the number of weeks that you
could collect unemployment if you were
laid off but they also redesigned the
system itself in 2011 Florida Governor
Rick Scott signed a law that moved the
state's entire unemployment application
process online the new system was
notoriously difficult to use no money
and no answers because of problems with
the state's new 63 million dollar
unemployment website in 2019 Florida
state auditor released a report on the
state's unemployment system it noted
that it frequently gave incorrect error
messages and would often prevent the
submission of an application entirely
honestly I'm an unemployment insurance
expert and some of the screenshots I've
been seeing don't make any sense to me I
talked to Michelle evermore an
unemployment lawyer and researcher it's
clear that there's a very intentional
movement to make benefits difficult to
access just by making the computer
system difficult first Florida's
unemployment application itself is
extremely difficult to complete think
about the last form you filled out
online you probably started at the top
with
basic identifying information then fill
in more boxes as you scroll down but to
submit a claim on Florida's unemployment
website you submit just a few bits of
information at a time then click to a
new page and hope it's all being saved
each time you hit submit in a new page
has to load that's a new opportunity for
the system to crash and kick you out the
website kept kicking you off while you
were trying to fill all these questions
you will just throw you to the beginning
of the website which basically made you
start all over again
thank you four times here we are 40
something days in I basically today
started from square one all over next if
you do get through the process it is not
active and when you click on that
nothing happens you just get this screen
of indecipherable stuff and you have to
try and figure out what it means
absolutely it was designed to fail some
Florida politicians have blamed the
systems problems on Deloitte the
contractor the state used to help build
the new online system back in 2013 but
that same year Deloitte also helped
Massachusetts build its online system
using the same basic framework
Massachusetts has been able to get
benefits to a much greater percentage of
jobless people than Florida everybody's
trying to blame the computer but in
reality it's the politics it's not the
computers fault the computer does what
you tell it to do in response to the
pandemic Congress gave States more than
a billion dollars to boost unemployment
benefits and made gig workers and
freelancers eligible for them but all
workers still have to go through state
systems like Florida's to get those
benefits
at some point in their working lives
four out of five Americans will need to
access safety net programs like
unemployment insurance but these
programs benefit that one out of five -
it keeps money churning in the economy
when there's a downturn for every dollar
spent in unemployment insurance benefits
a dollar 61 was generated in local
economic activity it's increasingly
clear that our physical health is linked
to that of our neighbors it turns out
our economic health is too
[Music]